this is Startalk welcome back to
Startalk radio live from the Marine
Memorial Theatre in San Francisco
California sketch fest 13 onstage with
me everybody's favorite Eugene Mirman
everybody's second favorite Dave Foley
and Superman
favorite Seth Shostak from the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence
Institute I'm your guest host Bill Nye
the Science Guy sitting in for my
beloved Neil deGrasse Tyson and you can
hear the excitement in the room because
it is the question-and-answer segment of
tonight's program ladies and gentlemen
first question comes from the back of
the room a guy in a black t-shirt with
white writing sir you said you're
looking for a narrowband transmission so
how do you know what band to listen for
I take it that questions directed to me
all right
the answer to your question is we don't
know the answer to your question right
we don't know what BAM but I mean you're
trying to second-guess what part of the
radio dial would et use is like the
bumper stickers right and there are
certain frequencies that are better in
terms of than you know not competing
with the natural noise of the universe
or because there are some natural
phenomena that produce radio waves at
that frequency so those frequencies
frequencies will be marked on the radio
dials of et as well as on our dial so
you have to guess we cover as much the
dial as we can but it's usually in the
microwave region if that means anything
to you
so between 1,000 and 10,000 megahertz
with that set along with this fantastic
gig I'm the CEO of the Planetary Society
we work to advance space science and
exploration for all humankind and we
also sponsor the optical search for
trucks extraterrestrial intelligence
where we are imagining that somebody
would send a light signal and we presume
generally there would be a laser signal
and it's Paul Horowitz at Harvard
with his brilliant grace and Curtis Mead
and they search for a light signal in
the same fashion thinking that somebody
out there the same way I of course I've
grown out of it the way I would once in
a while beam my flashlight straight up
hoping to send a signal deep into space
and they would go there's bill with
what's that mean yeah but it is
something that is what if how many
people have not shown a flashlight
straight up anyone how many people have
yes yes and there's just something that
we were thinking that maybe that is
something deep within a species and
somebody else is doing the same thing
and by the way seth shostack hosts his
own radio show are we alone no it's big
picture science big picture science it
just got renamed no I am sleeping bad we
got the other one
he has another radio show called let's
talk titties it's 24/7 yeah never stops
source of fascination my whole life so I
didn't know you were the host oh so we
have another question yes hey so what do
you think is the deal with the jelly
donut rock that the Mars rover just
found dudududududududud so I you know am
I on the periphery of the Mars team I
was a little bit involved with all three
spirit opportunity and curiosity this is
the opportunity Rover which was landed
in 2004 and it was post as you may know
was supposed to last three Martian
months but it's lasted ten years and so
poof so and that's why there and that's
why there's a new Jewish holiday
that's good grab this crowd
so think if you had a car with a three
year warranty
this thing has lasted 40 times it's worn
so it's your car you'd be driving a car
like that for 120 years with no
maintenance anyway so last week the
Rovers on a piece of Martian rock
fabulous that orange color that we all
know and love looking at pictures of
Mars those of us able-bodied with color
eyesight and so on and there it is and
then coupled Martian days later Sol's
later this white rock with a red middle
shows up in the next picture of the same
plate of rock and you know why nobody
knows why and so you start talking these
guys Steve Squyres principal
investigator Jim Bell one of the
geologists oh yeah this is like man this
is somebody's just full of manganese and
magnesium we got no idea what this thing
is
but to many of us what's a rock but
but it's an extraordinary thing
something happened on Mars right by this
Rover to produce this really noticeably
different thing not quite as big as a
baseball that tumbled into the frame now
it may be in the rover doing a pirouette
doing a pivot on its center almost it
chipped off something well if it chipped
off something and that's what this thing
is where is the off chip place that is
to say you would expect to find a
complimentary socket for this for this
ball or what have you and we haven't
seen that yet of course those guys were
going to go looking but it is not crazy
to suggest that there was a meteorite
impact a few meters away like over the
rover's shoulder and this is chin a
little pea spring playing didn't that's
a verb coined in the frame and wouldn't
that just be extraordinary and this
segways for me personally myself
speaking for myself it would indicate
just how frequently a place like Mars
gets hit with meteorites I'm not saying
that's what happened but it's not
unreasonable and it would remind us all
I hope that the threat of asteroids and
this is something that could bring the
world's population together
the only preventable natural disaster we
could go out there and give an asteroid
and nudge it's something to think about
and Seth how many asteroids
how many meteorites have amino acids I
don't know the answer to that but a lot
of them do I mean it's very very common
amino acids are easy to make them in
their garage he's with it so with that
let's take another question yeah we got
one over here man and plaid man in plaid
so I know nikola tesla was mentioned
earlier and he was a proponent of the
ephah theory and if that's gone away I
was wondering how does light propagate
through space if it's a wave how does it
travel forward if it has nothing to
travel through like wow that's a great
question so is everybody down with the
ether who isn't yeah so because sound
goes through air waves go through
people in the 19th century speculated
that there must be something through
which light propagated and we naturally
called this the ether naturally and then
you if there's an ether and the earth is
moving through space one would imagine
that if you did test to measure the
speed of light say going east and west
you would get a different answer than if
you measured it going north and south
because the spinning of the earth and
the motion of the earth in its orbit but
you don't
doot-doot doot-doot doot-doot doot-doot
it and so just as a guy who took a lot
of physics I would say light propagates
through space because it does and and
along that line if you do tests on your
probably hip to this stitch if you do
tests on light to get waves you get
waves and if you do experiment sunlight
to get particles you get particles and
so I always say I call that light has a
problem with us not understanding it and
so this is if you could figure that out
perhaps you could come up with the new
physics that would dare I say it change
the world but we can do these tests and
reproduce these experiments easily light
seems to travel through a vacuum fine it
is the essence of energy it is at pure
energy do we have another question okay
exhausted yes where's uh hi yes I was
wondering what do you think is the worst
misconception that our society has about
extraterrestrial life so that they need
a blanket that they
that they'd be interested in conducting
breeding experiments with with you
right that's not that that's just rude
with people I can't see who's asking the
question it's Ella I buy boy I would end
up breeding experiments with you
yeah don't think that they will either
mate with us or eat us they want neither
look at I you know occasionally I get
flown down to LA to consult with some
producers directors writers of sci-fi
films and you would think that they'd be
interested in this subtleties of maybe
new physics or the gentleman's question
about light which is a good question the
answer is is you know very subtle
actually but they're not interested in
any of that they're only interested in
three things they the Hollywood guys
they're interested in why are the aliens
here what do they look like in what sort
of weapons do they have cool yeah and
one day you'll get poor is have to atone
for something you can't say much about
that but one thing you can address I
mean what sort of weapons they have you
know Matt I always think of asking
Julius Caesar what sort of weapons do
you think the Legionnaires are going to
have in a year 2014 they say Oh big
Spears and good good ones yeah good one
yeah but but the question why are they
here right and that's really what you're
asking I think that that is a big
misconception that the public thinks
that they would come here for the water
or the molybdenum or the you know for
breeding experiments and so forth none
of that should interest then they can
find all that stuff and it would work
closer by okay and the other big
misconception they have is and this is a
requirement of storytelling for
Hollywood this is getting too serious oh
okay that they that they're always more
or less at our level that we can take
them on in dog fights or or you know we
can triumph via courage or low a bucket
on them or water yeah or just slugging
like Will Smith I mean then if if aliens
really came to earth you know it really
is Bambi meets Godzilla and we're worthy
Angela will be ungulate next question
this will be our last question
oh yeah this will what she means by that
is this will be the last question you
ever ask he's kidding I think make it
very long and then keep mumbling it as
you walk away to stay alive
um I know I'd heard something just sort
of mentioned in passing recently that
with all of the exoplanets that they've
been discovering recently they've
actually revised the Drake Equation what
changes did they make to it oh well the
number of planets hey what's the Drake
Equation we're there just to throw out
say as a for instance so Seth I think
that you're probably the world's
foremost authority Drake wise no I'm not
a Frank Drake is though and and as it
turned out it this is true believe it or
not yesterday I had Frank Drake explain
the Drake Equation when I aimed a video
camera Adam this was for some school
kids in Australia
you mean recorded him I reported on it
is a bit like a phaser to scare him
Frank Frank is totally unflappable all
the Drake Equation is just a very simple
series of terms that makes an estimate
of how many societies out there are
broadcasting signals that are going
right through you your bodies as you sit
through this soporific presentation
tonight okay so it depends on how many
stars are out there in what fractions
I'm have planets and stuff like that all
right
it's it's a series of fudge factors yeah
would you say so it's number of stars in
the galaxy number of stars that have
planets number of those planets that
would have earth-like or habitable
conditions if there are in the month I
mean so you multiply them all together
and you get an estimate of the number of
planets with that might be communicating
with us but I dare say that the young
lady who asked the question knows all
that yes she wants help in
always how do those terms change now
that we found a thousand exoplanets and
the answer is not much because when this
equation was cooked up in 1961 by a
dozen people in Green Bank West Virginia
right
they sort of bandied about what might be
good values to the terms in the equation
without knowing anything about planets
around other stars but they figured
maybe one in ten stars had planets or
one in ten of them might have a well one
in ten would have planets and all of
them would have at least one planet that
was habitable so that would be one in
ten stars has a planet that's habitable
there the current number we've heard it
tonight is maybe one in five that's
within a factor two for astronomy that's
really good not good for your taxes but
that's great for astronomy okay so in
fact if you look at those terms and you
say well we know a few of them a little
better not many of them actually but a
few of them a little better that change
is very minimal yeah a fact in astronomy
a factor of two what yeah III million
miles 186 what whatever 40 billion 50
billion you've heard it all you guys
this has been a fabulous evening thank
you all for coming here at the memory
Memorial Theatre in San Francisco
California Sketchfest 13 the guests have
been fantastic de Foley
Eugene Mirman seth shostack I've been
your host Bill Nye the Science Guy fly
safely and good night night